the wards Dame tony-nominated
critically-acclaimed
oscar-winner and national treasure have
all been used to describes tonight's
nominees for outstanding performance by
an actress in a supporting role but I
say they're simply the best the nominees
are Judi Dench in chocolate Marcia Gay
Harden in Pollock Kate Hudson in almost
famous
Frances McDorman in almost famous
Julie Walters in Billy Elliot
and the Oscar goes to Marcia Gay Harden
hi
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Marcia Gay Harden
thank you what is room members of the
Academy thank you
for taking the time to even view the
tape and consider our film ed Harris
thank you for inviting me to share your
passion you are a brave director and an
even braver actor and I love you dad
who's here tonight thank you for
teaching me how to soldier through tough
situations and mom for teaching me how
to do it gracefully - Fred burner Peter
Brant and Joe Allen thank you for
rearing this film and for ushering it
into the world Sony Pictures Classics
and especially Michael Barker to my
family and my agents and Mary Ellen
McKay he without whom I would never be
here my lawyer
my husband daddy is she all the people
who helped you in this crazy business I
want to thank you and for the inception
of the film James treasure and Barbara
Turner thank you